Say Yes to the Dress star Randy finoli
is engaged people coming together and
it's about love and family and petitions
no it wasn't a dress but he did say yes
to Forever announcing his engagement to
boyfriend mate Coble Randy shared this
pic of the couple celebrating their
special moment with a caption quote yes
it's official we're engaged we're so in
love Randy and mate's relationship began
earlier this year in January they met
while Mateo was a bar manager at a
luxury hotel in New York
Randy made his TV debut in 2007 as a
fashion director on Say Yes to the Dress
after first starting out as a fashion
designer in the 90s probably about 80
percent of the brides purchased the
First dress that they try on so looking
in the mirror like what else can
kind of our job to assure the bride that
just because she falls in love with the
First dress it's okay my advice is
always the same to really be true to
yourself and who you are as a couple and
I like to think of the couple as a brand
and the great thing about today's
weddings is that and today's wedding
dresses is that there's literally a
dress out there for every type of
writing and just a few years ago Randy
returned to his designing roots on the
show The reason I got back into
designing is because they have so many
brides that I've heard that come in and
say I want this dress but it's not in my
budget so I wanted to deliver dresses
that they could wear and feel beautiful
in and be in their budget I mean if you
look at my collection I've got dresses
that are over the top big princess I've
got dresses that are sexy I really try
to think of all types of brides to make
sure I have something within my
collection that will appeal to whoever
they are and their sense of style well
one thing we know for sure when it comes
to Randy's own wedding he'll definitely
have the perfect look
[Music]